الى العلاقات وحتى حديثنا بالرياضه كان
فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات ولكن عندما تشعر
مشاهد مشاهدنا الكريم ومشاهدتنا الكريمه
بانه شريكك لم يعد يهتم ودائم الانشغال
بامور غير مهمه فقد يشير ذلك الى انه
ينسحب بهدوء الباحث وبدلا من اتباع نهج
صحي ومواجهه الانفصال وجها لوجه قد يلجا
للبقاء في علاقه دون مشاركه نشطه ربما على
امل ان يبدا الطرف الاخر بالانفصال لانه
غير قادر على المواجهه بحسب اطباء علم
النفس في موقع
اذا اردت معرفه وضعك مع الشريك قم بتقييم
ما اذا كنت انت وشريكك تقومان بالطقوس
التي اعتدتما عليها ليالي المواعيد
العاديه او الوجبات المشترك او الانخراط
في الانشطه التي لديها اهميه لكيليك كما
هذه الامور البسيطه توفر البيئه الايجابيه
لعلاقتك لتكون وين في المسار الصحيح على
كل حال مشاهدينا سنتعرف مع الزميل علاء
بدايه على علامات تدل على ان شريكك ينسحب
من العلاقه فانتبهوا
اذا نتعرف على علامات تنبهك ان شريكك
ينسحب من العلاقه العاطفيه وفقا لما يؤكده
اطباء علم النفس اولها توقف الشريك عن
تخصيص وقت لك اذ يصبحوا دائما الانشغال
بامور اخرى تكون في اغلب الاحيان لا قيمه
لها ولا اهميه فهذا غالبا ما يشير الى
الرغبه في الانفصال ايضا ميل الشخص الى
البقاء في العلاقه دون التعبير عن مشاعره
او حتى اخفاء عواطفه ويتجنب تكوين روابط
عاطفيه حقيقيه ثم نتحدث عن بدء الرجل او
المراه في الكذب على الاخر وكانهما يرغبان
في التهرب من العلاقه ما يمثل فقدان الثقه
فيما بينهما ايضا التزام الصمت والهروب من
التحدث عن اي شيء متعلق بالمستقبل هذا يدل
ايضا على الرغبه في الانفصال ومن العلامات
كذلك الانسحاب من المواجهه او تجنب
الانخراط في مناقشات صعبه ولكن ذات مغزى
هذا يساهم في زياده الانقسام في العلاقه
واخيرا عدم بذل الجهد في الحفاظ على
العلاقه العاطفيه او الزوجيه وانخفاض
الرغب في الرغبه في استثمار الوقت والطاقه
والتفكير في رعايه هذه العلاقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا في الاستديو يا زوجان وصانع
المحتوى الدكتور الجراح فادي النحلاوي
وزوجته سما ضبيط اهلا بكم صباحكم دكتوره
والدكتور صباح النور
[ضحك]
طيب خلينا نرجع الى الشاعر يقول اذا وهى
الحب فالهجران يطفئه وان تمكن فالحجران
يحييه هذه العلاقه الزوجيه شراكه ربما
يصيبها برود
كيف من الممكن ان الزوجين من الممكن انه
دائما تكون علاقتهم مشتعله بهذه النار نار
الحب دافي العلاقه بلش
من اللي بيبلش
على فكره هذا اول سر انه يعطيها دائما
الاولويه يلا فهمني
كثير امور صغيره بتمرق بالحياه يعني احنا
ما بنعيش حياه مثاليه وقصه حب نحن اخذنا
بعض عن قصه حب عنيفه دمج شهرين فادي كان
مريضه بالعياده وتعرفنا على بعض وحبينا
فما نعيش بس مشان نطمن الشباب انه دائما
حب وحياه ورديه ومثاليه اكيد مرقنا بظروف
وحياه يعني ضمن ضغوطات الحياه وطبيعه
الشغل اللي بيشتغلوا يعني اجباري يعني بس
بضل
الاساس اذا في تفهم وفي حب وفي مواد اكيد
هالشيء بس انه الحب يستمر لن يستمر الحب
يعني وقت بيكون في قناعه انه في ثقه في
مواد في
تميز الارضيه صلبه اكيد حتمروا وبصير
تغاضي عن كل المشكلات الصغيره مثل ما قالت
ما في حياه مثاليه
انا بدي اكون شويه هيك صريحه يلا
انتم طبعا تعملوا بنفس المجال اطباء وبنفس
الوقت
بتصنعوا محتوى يعني دائما في يعني هذا
العمل مع بعض خلينا نقول ولكن هل مريتوا
بفتره مثلا دكتور انت كنت حاسس انه
الدكتوره متغيرت عليك مشاعرها قد تكون
تغيرت او العكس صحيح
بده يكون في فترات الانسان بده يشعر فيها
انه الشريك بجوز طبعا كيف بتحس يعني ايش
هي العلامات بالنسبه علاقتكم بانه في شيء
غلط
ابتعاد مثلا خاصه انا بقول لك حكيم بصراحه
الجانب النسائي اكثر مثلا اكثر هذا الشيء
بيلتمسوه من الجانب
الاخرين
انا قلت نحن رجال قد تكون انت رايحه عن
بالك انت ملتهي في ظهور شغلك في العمليات
انا من الصبح للمسا قد تكون اسهى بس انا
بقول اكيد اكيد هي بجوز تحس فيها يعني بس
انا بقول لك شغله اكيد اذا كان في انه ما
نخلي جوانب السلبيه تتفاقم اذا انا كان في
ثقه واذا كان فيه الموده اكيد بدي اضغطها
اي شيء والصراحه هاي اهم شيء
يعني هي قالت بنشتغل مع بعض بس الاختلاف
انه شغله جراحه اورام انا تقويم اسنان فهو
ستريس عمليات ضغط انا ريلاكس يعني دائما
الطبيب لا يقارن داخل غرفه العمليات او
خارج يعني مالنا عرفتي فانا دائما بقدر
انه هو كتير ستريس يعني انا بقدر انه هو
قد يعدي نهار كامل ما يتصل فيني بس بيكون
مثلا عمليته سبع ثمان ساعات اكيد انا لو
اتصلت ما حيرد علي بس انا ما حافسره انه
هو ما مهتم فيني ما حاببني
هو تفسير بضل تفسير ايجابي في قراءه
العلامات او تفهموها غلط تماما هي علامات
بدي اسالك قد يكون كتير تعب لفترات مثلا
فهون بيجي موضوع الصراحه انه في شيء صار
شيء يعني بيني وبينك وتغيرت اهم شيء اهم
شيء هاي النصيحه للشباب انه اي مشكله كانت
تنحل بنفس النهار ما التم لثاني نهار ما
تطلع برا البيت ما تتفاقم يعني للاولاد ما
ضروري يحسوا يعني اكبر مشكله للاولاد لما
بشوفوا
المشاكل
بنفس النهار بنفس الخيار على حسب درجه
احيانا تكون الظروف او الاجواء متوتره
بس اذا كان في نقاش عميق ولو مواجهه عميقه
وبتنحل بارضها لانه انت اي هلا في ناس
بقول لك تطنيش لا هذا عم يراكم شغلات
وبتبني شغلات علي وبتخلص لا خليه يصير
فيني خلص هلا المواجهه مش سهله احيانا انا
بدي اواجه بس لا لانه انت بتحس انه في شيء
بس اذا ما واجهت حد
خليها تخلص في نفس النهار ويمكن فعلا اذا
تركت تكبر تكبر اكثر من هيك طيب برضه ما
حدا فيكم راح يقول لي انه
العلامات الخاصه فيكم انتم مثلا انه مثلا
هو متعود يجيب لك ورده متعود
لا ورده وما ورده هذا يعني
15 سنه اكيد ما في ورديه يعني معلش
بالمناسبات بالمناسبه اكيد بالمناسبات
الروتيني يعني
بس يا عمي انا بقول لك كلمه حلوه بتسوى
100 ورده يعني هو متعود يجي يشوفني بالبيت
يعني
يعني لازم انا لو طبيب استقبله وانا حلبيه
من الطبخ الطراز ويعني لما بجي ما بشوفني
هو بشك وينك وينك دكتور فادي زايد
بالشك هاي مثلا احد العلامات وينك ليش
اذا ح
كى معي وهيك بس من نبره صوتي
[ضحك]
طويله بصير بالطاقه تماما
على زوجي بانه اشي بدون ما يحكي من الطاقه
اللي عملها بتطلع منه
والله نبره الصوت فعلا بتحبي شو الكلمه
اللي بتقوليها لا لا هو بحس
علي بنبره
بس تكون
يعني 15 سنه الله يديم المحبه ان شاء الله
والله
الدكتور الجراح فهد النحلاوي وزوجته ايضا
وشريكته واللي يفهم عليها
سما ضبيت شكرا جزيلا لكم
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوث والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات